[MUSIC PLAYING]
KAI HALEY: Using design
sprints to increase
cross-functional collaboration.
I'm Kai Haley.
I'm an interaction designer
leading the design relations
team.
And I'm also one of the leads
of our Sprint Master Academy.
And I'm joined today by a very
amazing group of Sprint Masters
from across a number of
product areas at Google.
And I'd like to
start off by having
them each introduce themselves.
So let's start off
here at the end.
JENNY GOVE: All right.
Hi, everyone I'm
Jenny Gove, and I
lead a team at Google that
works on the search [INAUDIBLE].
I'm also part of the
Sprint Master Academy.
RATNA DESAI: Hi, my
name is Ratna Desai,
and I'm a UX lead on the
search and assist team.
And I'm also part
of the Academy.
JOSH LOVEJOY: Yeah.
I'm Josh Lovejoy.
I'm a designer.
I work in the Research
and Mission Intelligence
part of the organization.
BURGAN SHEALY: Hi,
I'm Burgan Shealy.
I'm a designer as well
in Corporate Engineering,
which is the part of Google
that designs apps for googlers.
SUMIER PHALAKE: Hi, I'm
Sumier I'm a designer as well,
and I'm in a team called
Next Billion Users.
KAI HALEY: Wonderful.
Thank you all for joining us.
Today I wanted to start off
by giving a little background
on design sprints.
We started designs
sprints a while back
when some googlers got together,
and they wanted to experiment
with ways to increase
collaboration and innovation
for their teams.
And they did this
by taking methods
from design thinking, user
research, business strategy,
among others.
And putting them
into different orders
based on their challenge
and the deliverables
that they were looking for.
And they tested this and
prototyped it over time
to come up with a
core set of methods
that really yielded the best
results for their teams.
And in 2013, the
Sprint Master Academy
was founded to train googlers
in facilitating design sprints
using this core methodology.
We found it to be
really, really effective,
and so we have
basically adopted it
as a way of working
across Google.
People use the term sprints in
different ways in the industry.
I'm sure you guys have all
heard it used in different ways.
At Google, we define
a design sprint
as a tool for answering a
critical business question.
And we do this in five phases.
They're understand,
sketch, decide, validate,
and prototype.
And these phases have
been ordered together
to support divergent
and convergent thinking.
And this allows us to generate
a broad range of solutions
to our business
challenge, and allows
us to prototype the
solutions that we
think will be most
valuable for our users
and test them with users.
And we do this in
less than five days.
So this is a really fast
and intensive process.
Very excited to
get started here,
and I wanted to
dive in by talking
about the different
types of sprints
that people are running.
So tell us about the
different types of sprints
you're running for
your product area
and how you're structuring your
challenge and deliverables.
RATNA DESAI: So I've run
a variety of sprints,
and today I want to
talk about a couple.
Some are the
near-term sprints that
really focus on product
features and are
very much so for launching
a product immediately.
And then longer term sprints
that focus on visioning.
So for short-term
sprints, we generally
focus on things like if you're
at a strategic crossroads.
So for example,
for Google Express,
the team was deciding how to
expand the business nationally.
And we were looking at ways
to get more user retention
and focus in on retail
categories and verticals which
we hadn't in the past.
So in looking at the
kind of marketplace,
we wanted to place our
bets in the right vertical,
whether it be home furnishings,
grocery, or even apparel.
And so at that point, we had
run a variety of business models
and really modeled out the
solution from that perspective.
What we needed to complement
that decision making process
was a design sprint.
And at that point, when
we were at that juncture
and that inflection
point in the business,
it was a lovely time to
get everyone in the room
and really focus in on the
options that we could take.
And what that actually looked
like in terms of deliverables
was mocks, prototypes.
And we were able to kind
of line those up and decide
more consciously and
thoughtfully where
we wanted to place
our bets, and then
outline a roadmap
that would allow
us to get there within a year.
So we had some constraints.
But we worked within
those and were
able to ideate in a very
focused iterative manner
before we decided to really
commit to a strategy.
JENNY GOVE: I can
follow up on that.
So I run a number of
different types of sprints.
These range from visions
sprint, so vision,
about where we see a
product area, perhaps.
Also, I think what's very
common is product features.
We often run sprints to get
to new product features.
But also we have run sprints
to define new policy and also
new processes.
We've even done sprints to come
out with different principles.
And also to look at those
real moonshot ideas.
And you talked about
sprint challenge
and how we've structured that.
So a sprint challenge
is really this statement
you draw up at
the beginning when
you're planning the sprint.
And the challenge really has the
distinct defined aspects to it.
You need to know what
it is you're doing.
And that's the part that
I just talked about,
the vision or the process,
or the policy sprint
that you're planning towards.
And then you define kind
of who is the audience.
Who are you doing this for or
who's the participants for.
And the scope of that,
how far out you're
thinking, how long you're
going to take that.
And you talked about
structuring it.
I think communicating
it is really
important across the team of
people you're working with.
And then you get
different deliverables
assigned to those
different types of sprints.
So product features, obviously
that's really common as I said.
And there's a lot of
prototyping, different tools
used for prototyping.
And that's a very standard way.
But we also do some fun
things with vision sprints,
where we've done roleplays,
creating videos, what else?
So policy will be sort of
the first step of making
that text for the policy.
Process might be a diagram,
how you kind of set
up, say, a process for
checking on privacy
or checking on security.
And moonshot ideas often comes
down to roleplays and videos
again.
JOSH LOVEJOY: Yeah,
it's interesting
building off the point about
deliverables and scope.
The thing across all
the sprints that I found
is it's just as important,
if not more sometimes,
to define what's out of scope.
So knowing the things that
are going to be sort of out of
reach.
And there's a couple
important pieces why.
One is helping to define those
out-of-scope points gives you
a bit of license to
refine the conversation,
to focus the conversation.
People can go all over the place
over the course of three, four,
or five day design sprint.
And you want to
capture those ideas
and have them live
somewhere, but also
know that they're
going to always lean
towards the actionable
and the tangible,
the real world, not
too pie in the sky.
I worked on a
design sprint to try
to figure out the out-of-boxing
experience for a hardware
product.
And you can imagine
with a hardware product,
you can go any
number of directions.
It could be like from
how it gets manufactured,
to how the packaging
ends up at your doorstep,
to the delivery mechanism,
to opening the box itself,
all the way to
the hundredth use.
We really wanted to focus
into that first time use,
just that one experience
of having opened the box
and seeing what's inside.
And in doing that, it actually
gave a lot more confidence
from stakeholders to know
that we were actually
building towards something
testable and verifiable.
We weren't going to try to just
traverse this giant landscape
and cover it all, which
would have been impossible
in four days.
KAI HALEY: Thank you.
Yeah, that's a very
interesting example.
What would you say is
the most important thing
to do in preparing for a sprint?
JENNY GOVE: Should I
take this one again?
OK, so sprint preparation.
So facilitators have a role all
the way through the process,
right from the beginning,
right through past
the end of the sprint,
and making sure
that deliverables
come to fruition.
In the planning
process, that's a lot
of the time at the
sprint facilitator.
And during that time, they're
setting up the challenge,
like I talked about already.
And a large part
of that, though,
is making sure the right people
are going to be in the room
and building towards that
first stage in the sprint
that Kai talked about, which
is the understand phase.
Really, really critical
part of the understand phase
is delivering lightning talks.
And lightning talks are really
important because during that
time--
I'm sure many of you have been
engaged in design thinking
and used Post-it Notes to
write out your how might wes,
which is really opening
up opportunities.
So it's that lightning
talks that really
generate all those ideas.
So if you haven't done
really, really good
planning on your lightning talks
and who should be in the room
and who should be
talking to those,
so it might be
business development,
or it could be
somebody from legal,
or salespeople who have got
great deal of experience
with clients.
Setting that up really,
really well to make sure
you've got all that, what
I call food for thought,
to generate many,
many opportunities,
is a really key part
of the planning phase.
RATNA DESAI: So I
think I can build on
that because it's, in terms
of the most important thing,
I think it's definitely
planning, planning,
and then more planning.
And I want to emphasize
the fact that there
are unknowns during
a sprint, so you
have to even plan for those.
And what that looks
like is the agenda,
how you want to pace
the activities, who
do you want in the room.
And I would say that
after the planning,
it's really about the people.
And in terms of
which disciplines
you want in the room,
which personalities.
Because as a Sprint
Master, a facilitator,
you're essentially the
mediator to make sure
that the best ideas are
generated with this group.
And so it's kind of this active
facilitation that will happen,
and you need to plan
for it from the get go.
So it's seeding
the design sprint
early on with the right
people and the right plan
to make sure that you ensure
a platform where people
can really dream
and that people feel
very optimistic with each
other and safe to build
on each other's ideas.
And that was touched
on in the how
might we activity, which you can
read about on our Design Sprint
Kit website.
But it's really the concept of
optimism, right, in a Post-it
Note, which is while you're
listening to someone,
it's active listening.
And when that person is
talking, you yourself
are starting to
co-create with them
by writing down
the possibilities
and then doing a
share out at the end.
So just it's a really
lovely sacred space
for people to dream big.
BURGAN SHEALY: I also
think it's really important
to set expectations
so that everyone
knows what to expect on
the week of the sprint,
as well as to align everyone
on the deliverables that'll
come out of those
sprint, what the fidelity
of those deliverables
will look like.
And then how are you going
to follow up on the sprint?
What is the planning and the
resources for after the sprint,
so that everyone understands
and has the same expectations
for the sprint.
KAI HALEY: So it
sounds like there's
a lot of work that
goes into this,
and you have to start planning
pretty far in advance.
Is there a particularly good
time to sprint, or a time
when you absolutely
don't want to sprint?
SUMIER PHALAKE: Yeah, so there's
a couple of really good moments
in the product life
cycle when it's actually
really good to run a sprint.
So one of them is when
the product is really
in its early stages.
And it's just like
a kernel of an idea.
You don't know
what it looks like.
No one's really formed it
really well yet in their brain.
So that's a great time
to bring a lot of people
together
cross-functionally and get
a lot of experts in the room.
And then just kind of spend
a few days hashing it out
and coming out
with a good product
strategy, a good vision,
maybe a couple of hypotheses
that you want to test out.
So I think that's a great
time to jump on a sprint.
The other time is
actually later on,
when your product is actually
launched, and you have data,
and some of it is
working really well.
And then maybe
parts of it are not.
So for example, it's a shopping
site, and the check out flow
is not working well.
You're losing users.
So how do we fix this one
experience or this one journey?
And that's actually a really
nice tactical contained problem
to solve with a group of people.
You can expect to have a
really nice solution by the end
of four or five days.
And you can actually
think laterally, right?
Like as a group, you can
think of four or five
different solutions,
and then diverge,
and then converge on to the
ones that make the most sense.
So it really speeds
up the process
instead of doing this
regular waterfall model where
you design something,
you test it out,
then you go back to
the drawing board.
You actually do it
in parallel, and then
you explore a bunch of options.
And then at the end
of the week, you
have a really good solution.
When not do sprint actually
is really interesting.
So don't sprint when
you don't have time.
And so if you've seen
the iceberg example, what
you see on the day of the
sprint is actually just the tip
of the iceberg, right?
All the planning that
happens to make the sprint
a success, which is the majority
of the iceberg you can't see.
So it takes a while
to plan this thing
and set it up for success.
And if you don't have
the time to do it,
if someone says I want
to sprint next week,
just say no, it's
not going to happen.
And then also don't do it when
your team doesn't have time.
You're in the final
stages of launch,
everyone's head's down, trying
to get something out the door.
That is absolutely the wrong
time to try to run a sprint,
because no one's in
the right mindset
to go back to the drawing board.
You'll get a lot of resistance.
Make sure you get a
cross-functional team.
You can do a sprint
with designers,
but what's the point?
Because a lot of
it is about getting
cross-functional
consensus and buy-in.
You want people to
co-create and feel
like they have
ownership in the design.
And if you can't
do that, then you
lose something really valuable
from the sprint process.
And then lastly, I don't know if
you guys have experienced this,
but sometimes you'll
have a stakeholder who
has a solution in their brain.
And they're like, I
want to run a sprint,
because I want to validate that
what I have in mind is true.
And that's also not a
good time to run a sprint,
because sprints are
very, very bottom up,
and you have to allow
the space for people
to come up with their own ideas.
And sometimes they're
going to completely defy
your expectations,
and that's OK.
And if your stakeholders
are not all right with that,
then you shouldn't run a sprint.
RATNA DESAI: I think the
best time to run a sprint--
and this is coming
from the perspective
of working at Google,
which is a very, very
large organization with multiple
organizations within it--
is really when we
start annual planning.
So our OKR process
is quite rigorous,
and it's a good time to start
at the beginning of the year,
or I would even say at
the end of last year,
the previous year, so
that you can really
get runway on these ideas,
and then refine them quarter
by quarter.
And so what this
allows is it allows
that kind of
cross-pollination of ideas
very early on in the planning
stage of the business strategy.
And so it's key to
get there early.
The other point to make
about the best time
is that it's really when the
right people are in the room
and are craving alignment.
If there's no shared vision,
for example, for a product,
and people are just kind of
stumbling and misinterpreting
the goals, those things
are good symptoms
to pay attention to
in any organization,
and to really then address it
with this wonderful methodology
that can stem anywhere from
a couple hours of getting
together and gaining that
alignment, or several days.
And so this investment and
this customization can happen,
and that's what's really
lovely about this sprint method
that we have.
And the wrong time is
when you really don't
have the right
people in the room,
because it's ultimately going
to lead to a product idea that
isn't fully fleshed
out or doesn't
have the right stakeholder
investment upfront.
So that kind of
upfront investment
is so valuable down the road
when you're launching product.
And it really saves teams
so much time in the end.
JOSH LOVEJOY: Yeah,
you bring up the point
about when teams are sort of
stuck in a product lifecycle.
I've seen sprints unstick
teams so many times.
The test I like to
run is if someone
writes a doc about a
feature or a product,
and then the email thread
that spawns out of that doc
is longer than the
doc itself, it's
probably a pretty good time
to get some people in a room
and talk.
You're frequently
dealing with this kind
of cognitive dissonance
of like, well,
taking a bunch of people offline
and putting them in a room,
and having them just talk to
each other for multiple days.
That's like a ton of
investment, and we're
going to lose all
sorts of productivity.
And the secret is
actually you gain
like months of productivity.
If you get people from
different disciplines who
have different perspectives
and different backgrounds who
can come together and align, you
save so many different cycles
of churn and back and forth.
I even recently
we had a situation
where a product I
was involved with
had some research
findings come back
that were pretty surprising
and pretty at odds with some
of our core belief systems.
And we rallied together
a diverse set of folks
for like three hours
and came up with--
just presented the
research, talked
through a bunch of common
themes we were seeing,
and by the end of
that session, we
had product tenets that now
have taken us into a point where
we're ready to launch.
And that's just crazy
amounts of efficiency gain.
KAI HALEY: You all mentioned
a cross-functional team
and getting the right
people there in the room.
Can you talk a little bit about
the most successful composition
of roles for a sprint?
Sounds like that's
really important.
RATNA DESAI: Yes.
And I think it was touched
on earlier, is that I call it
kind of the trifecta, right?
You need your
product manager, you
need your [INAUDIBLE] partner,
and you need your UX person
in the room.
Now that said, it's really
dependent on the challenge.
Oftentimes, if we're solving
for a health care business
challenge, I want a physician.
And if I can't get a
physician in the room,
I certainly want an interview
with a subject matter expert.
So there are these
ways in which we
can augment the
core working team
with stakeholder interviews,
subject matter, expertise.
And it really goes a long way,
because you're essentially
creating this real
microcosm of what
we call a sprint team, which is
essentially practicing what it
means to be a growth org,
right, a constantly learning
and evolving organization.
And we do these in these
little sprint pods,
but essentially it can be
applied to the entire company.
Our technology is moving fast.
We're all kind of moving a
million miles an hour in terms
of what we're going to produce
and put out in the market.
So it's really
our responsibility
to get that trifecta and
the right people in the room
because the audiences and the
global audiences we relate to
with our end user is so diverse,
that really the onus is on each
of us to make sure
that the seeds planted
and the DNA of this idea
that will eventually become
a product living
in someone's life
is a reflection of
society at large.
And so you want those
kinds of cultural nuances,
you want the diverse
perspectives.
And I can't emphasize
this enough.
It's so important to have that
filter when you start a design
sprint, because it really
shapes the end deliverable.
I've seen teams where
that kind of team synergy
and that diversity has
led to true innovation,
and I think authentic team
spirit, which really matters.
Because we want people returning
to these sprints and to do them
as their active product
development practice.
So it's really important that
we make their time worthwhile
and that they feel that
they get a lot from it.
JENNY GOVE: I'll
just add that I've
had experience bringing in
different sorts of people
in different roles at Google
into different sprints.
So some success
stories I can remember
were running a sprint for games,
around games, and around apps
for games, when I brought
in business development,
and they had such a different
perspective than we'd
heard before, that we
hadn't involved before that.
I've run sprints on
privacy and security.
We definitely brought in legal.
We brought in policy.
We also at that time brought
in external academics
into our sprint teams.
So sometimes thinking
even wider than the people
in your company, where you can
do that is really important.
And like I said
before, teams that
have the client perspective
often a lot better than we do.
Definitely bringing in user
research, but also sales,
developer relations,
different roles
like that such a good
connection to the end users.
KAI HALEY: Great.
So have any of you
guys had any sprints
that you considered to be
maybe a little bit of a failure
or went off the rails?
And what did you
do to save them?
SUMIER PHALAKE: I've had a few.
So I ran a sprint recently.
So I work in a group that makes
products for emerging markets,
and I was working
with a team that
really wanted to be in this
one particular emerging market.
And I planned the
sprint perfectly,
and everything was
going really well.
And there were a bunch of
really great lightning talks
based on really strong
foundational research,
and what we found out was none
of that research was actually
presenting a strong user
need or a user problem.
And so what ended
up happening was
over the course of
that sprint, everyone
had a lot of great
ideas, but no one really
knew what a good idea was
because they didn't know
what they were solving for.
And so I've been
very guilty of this.
Before the sprints runs,
I was just like, hey,
throw your lightning
talks into the slide deck.
As long as the lightning
talks are done, I'm happy.
And I'd rarely actually
go through them
and try to synthesize
and try to understand
if the inputs
actually make sense.
And so my learning was if
your inputs aren't great,
your outputs aren't
going to be great.
So you have to make sure that
you use your inputs in a way
to guide the team to come
to really good solutions.
The other situation I've
faced is just personalities.
Sometimes you will have a really
loud, strong voice in the room.
You've all been in
sprints where there's
been a super senior executive
or someone super senior who
is very opinionated, and
everyone else kind of
feels scared to oppose them or
come up with their own ideas.
And this is where your
skills as a Sprint Master
really come into play.
You have to point to other
people and ask them to speak.
You have to keep
reminding people
that sprints are
very democratic.
And if voting is not
working for you--
because sometimes someone
will vote for an idea and then
everyone else will vote
for that same idea--
you should try doing the note
and vote method where people
can write down their votes on a
piece of paper with no one else
seeing, and then you
tally them up after.
I've always had, there's
always this one person
in the sprint who is
convinced that their idea is
the right one, and
everyone else is wrong.
And for that, what I've
found is really successful
is you just give them the stage.
Because if you don't
let them speak,
it's just going to keep
bubbling up for days.
So just give them the
stage; let them speak.
Again, remind everyone
that this is a democracy.
And then after
they've had their say,
if still no one agrees,
then it's really
like there's nothing
else they can do, right?
So that's been really
effective for me.
BURGAN SHEALY: I like to
say there are no failed
sprints, because you always
learn something from a sprint.
That being said,
there's always a chance
for your sprint to go
in a different direction
than you planned.
Sometimes that can
be a good thing,
and sometimes it's
really important
to bring the sprint team back to
the original sprint challenge.
Occasionally I've
had teams that get
really excited and gravitate
towards solutions that
are cool or shiny, but don't
really address the user
problem in the best way.
So that's when having a
pre-defined sprint challenge
is really important, and
having your success metrics
and your design
principles defined,
so that you can
refer back to them
and make sure that you're really
addressing the problem that you
set out to address.
Another challenge I've
faced is keeping everyone
engaged for the full sprint.
It's a big chunk of time.
I was in one sprint where
we had a key participant--
someone who was really
important to the sprint--
leave after only
two hours, after he
discovered that we were pretty
serious about our laptops
down policy.
He said he could only
participate in the sprint
if he could be on his
laptop the whole time.
So we actually decided to
do daily checkins with him,
half hour checkins at the end
of each day, to get his feedback
and make sure that he knew
where the sprint was going,
but that would not interrupt the
flow of all the other sprinters
with that distraction.
JOSH LOVEJOY: Yeah,
I had one early
on when I was learning
the ropes of design sprint
facilitation, where I bit
off way more than I could
chew, a little bit unknowingly.
I signed up to
facilitate a sprint
to redesign the
hiring at Google.
Super, super easy.
And it was like 20 people
from all over the company
with very different parts
of the company represented.
It was like the second
sprint I facilitated.
And it had all of the things.
It had all of the earmarks
that I should have--
I now know to be on the lookout
for-- of a lot of baggage
between different parts
of the organization.
A lot of people with very
specific ideas to the points
that both of you have made.
Also when I started getting
involved in the project,
there were zero UX people.
And so I sought
desperately to find
a couple of people that
could just bring some design
thinking to the process.
So then we started, and
then things were terrible.
And it was like
time was slipping,
there were so many
competing ideas.
There was this one
person who just
couldn't get over
their own ideas
and kept bringing it
back to themselves.
And just with the sheer
size of that group,
it's almost impossible to track
down and sort of pay attention
to everyone's thoughts.
So I had these little moments
where I'd like, OK, break time.
And then I'd go almost
cry in a corner.
And so around the middle of
the second day, I was like,
I'm pretty sure I've failed the
company and everyone's going
to hate me.
And so I did the only
thing I thought I could do,
which is just trust the
planning that I'd put into it.
And I came back, and I was a
little bit more firm with time,
and I called time, and I focused
people around the objectives.
I also paid a lot more attention
to some of those unspoken
signals of democratic thinking
to direct attention to the ways
that people were aligning,
even as this one person was
disrupting and derailing.
And in some instances, I needed
to even take that person aside
and have some hard
conversations.
And I was just like, listen,
this is either going to work
or it's not.
And somehow, near the end of
that day, we sort of found it.
And there was enough visibility
into people's shared vision
of what was going to be
built that we ended up
with a pretty amazingly
successful process that right
now is being experimented
with across the company, which
was pretty cool.
KAI HALEY: Cool.
It Sounds like you really
have to expect the unexpected
as a Sprint Master
and be ready to pivot
and trust the process is
what I hear you guys saying.
Outside of the standard
product development process,
what are other use cases
that you've applied
the sprint methodology to?
So I've done quite a few
sprints for nonprofits.
And I know Burgan has, too.
I've been very
passionately working
with nonprofits
for several years.
And I used to do UX
workshops with them.
And then after I learned
the sprint methodology,
I started doing sprints.
And that's actually
been really effective
because nonprofits actually
have interesting challenges.
Unfortunately, they
don't often have a lot
of budget for UX resources.
And so things like
design thinking and stuff
like that, they just
don't have the luxury
to actually have the
right people to help
them think through that.
But having said that,
they are actually
super excited to
work with designers.
They face some of the same
organizational challenges
that we face, like getting
stakeholder, buy-in, changing
things that they've
done the same way that
have tried and trusted
for many, many years.
A lot of times, they're
stuck using legacy systems
that they want to break out of.
So it's been actually really
great working with them
to kind of get a consensus
to change product direction.
Having said that,
I think if you're
running a sprint
with a nonprofit,
I think it's really,
really important
to staff them with even more
UX designers as participants
than you would otherwise.
And that's because
in my experience,
there's not a lot of knowledge
about things like user journeys
or sketching or
flows or just some
of that terminology we
take for granted now.
There isn't a lot of
experience with that.
So it kind of need
more of a helping hand.
And every time I've
actually had more UXers
on the team, if you split
the team into groups,
each group should have a UXer.
It's worked out
really, really well.
The other sprint I
recently ran was--
I don't know if anyone's
read Jake Knapp's medium
article about a brand sprint--
the product that I'm
b working on Google
is really ready
for a rebranding.
And so I spent three hours
with key stakeholders
just defining the
personality of our product,
our vision for 20 years, who
we are, what our values are.
And that was a super
great for just getting
everyone aligned, getting
all these abstract notions
of what our brand
is into something
that was really concrete.
So then we actually start
deploying that brand as a logo
or in marketing,
we have something
to point to and keep
ourselves honest
and make sure we're
not off-brand.
so that was actually
really great.
BURGAN SHEALY: Yeah, I've
run a number of sprints
with nonprofits as well.
Several for google.org, which
is Google's philanthropic arm
as well.
And I think one of
the key differences
that I've enacted with
nonprofits, for instance,
is having users in
the entire sprint.
So in one, the nonprofit
Project Concern International
was using satellite data to
give and show pastoralists
in sub-Saharan Africa
current vegetation
so that they could understand
where good grazing land was.
This was becoming a problem
due to climate change,
and their grazing
lands were changing.
So the program that
they had was hugely
successful with a 50%
reduction in herd mortality
and 80% adoption by
local populations.
However, the delivery system
was really ineffective.
They were printing out
maps, paper maps, and then
hand delivering those
to the local population.
So our challenge was to provide
these maps on a smartphone.
So we had Google UXers,
we had PCI staff,
we had a mapping specialist,
we had local developers.
And then we had a number of
users in the sprint with us.
And having the users in
the sprint was critical.
They were able to work
with the developers
to really help the
developers understand
the user needs from the
very outset of the project.
The UXers were able to
understand the technology
challenges and opportunities.
And just having the users as
code designers in the process
was really important so
that they owned the solution
and actively worked with the
team to develop the solution.
[MUSIC PLAYING]